[Music]  if you've been keeping up with Kylie  Jenner she's been pretty m.i.a since  rumors of her pregnancy but the reality  TV family hints at a big reveal on a new  teaser of Keeping Up with the  Kardashians get ready for a two-night  event full of Kardashian's surprises  because when it comes to making  announcements the family's got news so  big kylie is seen facetiming her mom and  sisters Kourtney Kim and Khloe while she  appears to be lying in bed could she  finally reveal she's expecting  chances are it's Khloe officially  announcing her exciting baby news to her  friends and family as she is pregnant  with her first child I feel great that I  feel so good I think just it's just all  like weird what's happening I think it's  just like you're growing a human but  we'll have to wait and see how it all  plays out on keeping ups two nights  special this Sunday and Monday on E I'm  excited about it  [Music]